طلاب البكالوريوس الاجانب في بريطانيا لن
يتمكنوا من احضار افراد عائلتهم بتاشيره
دراسيه فقط طلاب الدراسات العليا
والمنضمون في برامج بحثيه مثل الطالب
السعودي فواز عبد الله يسمح لهم بجلب
عائلتهم قرار تعتبره وزاره الداخليه جزءا
من اجراءات الحد من صافي الهجره المرتفعه
في البلاد بكل تاكيد لو كان القراره هذا
ساري وقت ما انا وصلت البريطانيا او فكرت
اني ابتعت البريطانيا اكيد راح اغير
الدوله لانه فعليا انك تجلس خمس سنوات
بدون عائله هذا شاي هذا شيء صعب فلذلك
افضل اني اروح لدوله اخرى مثل امريكا او
كندا على سبيل المثال
وفق الارقام الرسميه فان السلطات اصدرت
نحو 136 الف تاشيره طالب العام الماضي
مقابل 16 الفا في 2019 ما زاد عدد
المعالين من الطلاب الاجانب بثمانيه اضعاف
ومساهمه في الاقتصاد محدوده فيما نظام
الهجره غير مصمم لاعداد كبيره من الهجره
الوافده
هذا هو الشيء الصحيح والعادل الذي يجب
القيام به ويضمن اننا نحمي خدماتنا
وامدادات الاسكان من ضغوط لسنا بحاجه
اليها حتى نفي بالوعود التي قطعناها
لتخفيض صافي الهجره
القيود الجديده ستمنع ايضا استصدار تاشيره
عمل الطلاب قبل انهاء دراستهم وستلاحق
السلطات من تسميهم بعاديمي الضمير الذين
يستغلون تاشيرات الطلاب كوسيله للهجره
اجراءاته خفض مستويات الهجره الجديده هذه
المره تثير قلق الجامعات البريطانيه التي
تخشى خساره مصدر مهم لارادتها حتى وان
التزمت الحكومه باستراتيجيه التعليم
الدولي لجلب 600 الف طالب دولي للدراسه في
بريطانيا كل عام بحلول الفين مصطفى
العربيه لندن لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات